Greetings, everybody.
My name is Sam Deiter, and I'm a senior Unreal Engine
instructor with Epic Games.
In the following introductionary video tutorial series,
we're going to be taking a look at Groom, which
is Unreal Engine 5's solution for rendering hair
and fur.
We're going to first start this tutorial series
by taking a look at what Groom is so we can get
more familiar with what we can do with Groom when
it comes to Unreal Engine 5.
We're then going to take a look at how we enable
the various Groom plugins.
Then we'll take a look at importing Groom assets.
We'll explore the Groom tool settings,
as there are quite a few tools within the Groom editor
that you can use to help performance in the look
and feel of your Groom assets.
We'll also take a look at creating Groom materials that
are set up specifically so that they
can interact with the hair and allow you more control
over how the hair looks and reacts when
it's placed on your assets.
We'll then a look at applying Groom to assets
and follow up that with Groom shadow and lighting.
So we've got a lot to cover.
Let's go ahead and get started
with our Groom overview.